ha-ah better protect your bubble calm
proud sponsors of swype on Sky News
you're watching slight on the show this
week shocking thought using electricity
to boost your brain power it may be 3d
but it ain't speedy why this car has
been making headlines and things get
strange in our games of you hello and
welcome to strike now I'm going to be
straight with you from the start on the
pipe team we've been a little bit afraid
about filming this episode you see when
we heard the science museum was laying
on an event based around human and
heartless we thought great but then we
heard an involved electric stimulation
yeah so for this episode I've got my
rubber soled on these scientists are
experimenting with using electricity to
enhance their brain power transcranial
direct current stimulation or tDCS for
short works by sending currents through
your scalp the aim is to boost
concentration when we use to this year's
you can in some cases improve
performance it depends on several
parameters like the type of the current
that you're going to deliver where do
you put the electrodes on the head
research has shown that it is risk-free
but it is been done on a very very
narrow population I would not recommend
anyone to do this at home left goes to
left dorsolateral well one man who is
less concerned about those risks is dirt
Briere he made his own tDCS device using
parts bought from electronic stores
because he was intrigued by the concept
it's certainly passing the current
because I can feel a tingling sensation
which is what most people think feel it
tends to quiet down the sort of internal
chatter you get when you're doing
something you want to concentrate on you
don't get a little voice that says oh
I'm feeling hungry what about what I
gonna have for dinner or whatever
you just tend to concentrate a bit metal
a little bit better on the task DIY
devices aren't the only source of
electric brain stimulation available for
enthusiasts you can also find more
high-end products online like focus a
headset which claims to boost
concentration levels for gamers another
is the brain stimulator which markets
itself as the smallest device of its
kind and even has a travel model as the
market grows experts say it needs to be
monitored direct-to-consumer tDCS
devices should be regulated mainly to
protect consumers it's not that we think
devices should be particularly
prohibited or restricted but that
consumers should be able to use devices
that are as safe as they can be for the
purpose for which they're using it
there's still lots more research being
done into the positive and negative
effects of tDCS but if you've ever felt
your morning coffee isn't giving you the
boost you need then maybe one day this
could be the alternative Chris Cregan
Sky News so that's one way to boost the
brain but why stop there let's boost our
fences to joining me now Miranda and
Joseph winners of a competition called
hack the brain which was all about
expanding the mind and augmenting our
senses tell us about your software so
yeah are good what's good and Agra free
and the idea has been styled so sadly
can be here tonight but it's a based on
emotional cartography and Ben's idea is
that we could map for emotions to gps it
you have a map of how you're feeling as
you're walking around ok and these
electrodes on you right now these our
electrodes recording right now ok so
what's this telling us so this one
here's my heart rate just quite a simple
beat the news on terror above my eye on
my left and right hemisphere and
when I'm blinking you can see you get
this quite big deflections and if I
close my eyes you get arrested out there
okay so how would you want to use that
though in real life I'm quite interested
in terms of autism spectrum disorders
and depression to give a motion of
people who are necessarily tell you how
they're feeling so might you be able to
personalize treatment perhaps in the
future maybe something like that
depending to see how people's moods are
compared to the drugs that they have and
Joseph tell us a bit about what you were
wearing so I'm wearing a consumer EEG
device which is very similar to hers but
a bit more tests with wearing out in
public okay and why would you want to
wear that out in public cuz what can it
tell you so you can as Miranda said you
can measure the difference in amplitude
in the earth way to the front of your
brain and we are looking to kind of by
taking the later science create and so
for me about how generally positive are
generally negative you feel we want to
map that into where you are in the city
learn about where people feel unhappy
okay so around the city you want to be
able to see what emotions people are
feeling so marginal to do that how
useful is that that's if you have an
older relative you might have dementia
and we're trying to learn how they feel
throughout the city this would tell them
without them being even if they couldn't
physically tell you this could possibly
tell me you're watching quite still on
the way we thought electric brain
stimulation Sounders Gary but wait till
you see what's happening in our games
review but first here's a roundup of
some of this week's other tech news
twitter has launched a free live
streaming video out for your iphone
periscope lets you broadcast live
notifying your followers so they can
choose to watch comment and send you
hearts the app is being seen as a rival
to meerkat which launched last month the
hugely popular minecraft is about to
boost lessons in Northern Ireland a
special educational version of the
building block video game is set to be
given to every secondary school there as
part of a government-backed project it's
to help teach subjects like science and
engineering check out China's first 3d
printed car the two-seater convertible
took five days to make and runs on
rechargeable batteries the designers say
the material is
I to the metal and will help save energy
in the future although don't expect to
get anywhere too fast the cars top speed
is 40 kilometers or 24 miles per hour a
project on the crowdfunding site
Kickstarter is hoping to teach us how to
be disciplined the K safe only opens
when you've achieved your goals whether
that's the number of steps covered or
when you reach a location and once it's
locked there's no way of overriding it
well if transcranial direct current
stimulation isn't for you perhaps a bit
of gaming will get your engine revving
here's our reviewer cameron robinson
without the biggest game coming out this
week is blood-borne the blood Barra is
from the guys who brought you big games
like Dark Souls and demon souls and for
anyone who's played these games before
you'll know they're all about being
really difficult and trying to figure
out through a lot of death how to
progress beyond that point in the game
so it's a third person action game you
come up against really nasty creatures
and it's set in this dark grimy
Victorian London type of landscape but
as I say it's all about tactical
fighting so you're sometimes
encountering loads of different enemies
at once and to try and separate them
from the others and taking out one by
one so it's a game full of style and a
lot of substance but most of all it's
really tricky oh great fun another game
that's coming out this week which is
actually our call back to gaming of
yesteryear you might say is game called
pillars of eternity and it's based on
the classic dungeons and dragons esque
RPGs a lot of influence from the world
of tabletop gaming as well but em it's
based it's kind of a classic dungeon
crawler so you have your team of of
various different warriors and you're
searching out for loot and things like
that but it really is old school in its
nature and then it's interesting because
it was it was crowdfunded so there was
enough of an appetite out there and in
the industry for an old style of game
like this to appear today and it's been
made by a development team called
obsidian who have made some really big
games like fallout new vegas but the
game is it seems to be doing really well
it's very difficult the combat is very
tactical you're controlling lots of
different people at once on screen
casting spell
and doing attacks but none of them have
any artificial intelligence so they
don't attack on the room so you need to
kind of manage micromanage everything at
once which is challenging but it's just
really good partner
this week we see the second chapter of
life is strange hitting digital stores
and if you haven't played the first
chapter you really should my entire life
has been changed in just 24 hours it's
an adventure game so it's all about
making decisions as you progress through
the story the cool thing about life is
strange is if you make a decision you
see the consequences you don't like
those consequences you can rewind time
and try different routes so you don't
have to replay the whole game to see the
different possibilities and consequences
from your actions you can just rewind
time but in the second episode which is
coming at this week everything gets a
lot darker so if you're following the
story is a lot more intrigue a lot more
danger and basically the morale of the
second episode is like very small
decisions can have huge consequences so
if that sounds interesting should
definitely check out life is strange
I'll be your faithful chauffeur and
companions well this week's episode
might have seemed a little bit out of
this well but at least it wasn't as
scary as we first thought it was going
to be I'll see you next time for Moore's
wife and until then you can stay up to
date with all the latest tech stories on
sky knees for iPad or smartphone apps
guyanese calm and YouTube bye-bye
Archer ah better protect your bubble
calm proud sponsors of swype on Sky News